thank you
at a time of such challenging places
like you tell your friends that we're
very lucky to have our leadership we're
very lucky to have a surgeon because
confidence trust me on this you don't
have to spend too long Investments of
these days to realize what happens when
that kind of sovereign
we have to start they often say that
first impressions are important in any
new job well only I'm after the weeks
into their new rules the disastrous day
of this trust
me upon me sent upon everything put
Pension funds at risk and freaked meet
him for mortgage holders
[Music]
in the history of UK politics
for us
Congress mentioned be quick he'll change
his mind again
you know there was at least one story
here
[Music]
economics
but what was once again
because
painfully unordinary households
foreign
Ty
already you're dealing up to make real
terms parts of the benefits in this
middle under the cost of living crisis
[Music]
every year
foreign
subconscious
here's a test for the new conservative
levels
there's any sense of morality if they
have any backbone who will join us
[Music]
conference yes
[Music]
that those insulted aren't distracting
one little bit we've got the message
of the last few weeks
described it this is
control
[Applause]
a price that Scotland can't afford to
pay any longer but at this conference
the reality is that it kills of the last
few weeks has no no exception it has
become the new Norm of a British
politics
and crisis
in 2016 and they've been driving towards
disaster ever since
you only to fall into the arms of the
international monetary fund and who can
forget that these are the same people
who once promised to Take Back Control
well the last few weeks of the clearest
evidence is just how dangerously they
have lost control we are no less
[Music]
right-wing Records who should never be
alone anybody in the privilege of power
ever ever again
so let us the responses meaning the
problem let's never allow them to pull
over our lives ever ever to have control
over the Scottish people ever again
[Applause]
[Music]
for good
s
the opportunities
so we only have to look at the current
context
sovereign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
potential
yesterday
[Music]
the Lord ahead and the opportunity
before us
[Music]
ing
opportunity transition that disappears
Net Zero and enhances energy
costs for consumers
every single year
and an investment that it could sustain
385
000 dwarves
the green sustainable growth for the
long term
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and of course
that's not all as well as pledging
enough support for brexit the nameless
other big plans it is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
who also believe in Independence
leaving
I know he breaks it back in the
Democracy denying totally enabling party
don't forget
don't forgive
I am very confident that the Scottish
people never will
one could see uniform Better Together
[Music]
right brexit is being used
by the people of this country
please torture the Lord's brexit bills
give UK ministers
without the consent of the Scottish
Parliament without the consent of the
people of Scotland
this new program also carries the real
risk that laws protected in racing
standards
eater a week as well as good deer and
water quality will follow me and
disappear and all because the victories
of hell bent on getting rid of any law
any right any protection as the world's
European Union in it
we haven't sovereign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
belongs
[Music]
in life is a rich reminder of those who
came before us those who first believed
to fail for our country's Independence
his was
[Music]
and a nuclear purpose they are needed us
they are lost but thankfully for
softness we no longer have to be bound
by their choices and their control
we have the chance of a different choice
the choice of a different future because
[Music]
with an independence we have a clear
purpose and in a clear path
in Hamilton
out of the doors of Westminster for the
very last time
[Applause]
Hamilton
and for all those that have gone before
but those of us in sovereign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]